(audience applauds)
- You got a good birthday coming up later,
and it's the big 3-0.
- The big 3-0.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] The big 3-0.
I love my thirties.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
No, you always talk about your thirties.
- My twenties were hard.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Well, just-
- 'Cause I was lonely.
I didn't have a band.
(Niall and Kelly laugh)
It was lonely.
- That's why it's so much
fun here with this band.
- Yeah.
I love my band.
I just mean, it's hard,
like when you're in the spotlight that,
that to like, you know,
just communicate what that's like.
So, I was, yeah.
Twenties were hard,
but thirties were cool.
You're gonna love it.
- My twenties were fun.
I had a great time.
(audience laughs)
- Whatever, Niall.
(Niall laughs)
- I was, no, I was having a
great time in my twenties.
I really enjoyed it.
- Do you freak out about age?
Are you freaking out about it?
- No.
I'm one of those people
I couldn't care less, honestly.
- [Kelly] Me too.
- I like ...
everybody talks about the thirties
being the new twenties, so-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm up for it.
I feel older.
My hangovers are worse.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] Harder?
- Jesus, they're very long.
- Your knees as well.
- You know what I mean?
The knees.
- I know.
Soccer is hard on you.
- Yeah, (laughs) yeah, it is.
But no, I'm looking forward to it.
I, I, my best friend since
I was like three years old,
his parents and my parents were
in the same class at school.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- We were in the same class at school.
His name is Mully.
And um ...
- I'm sorry, Mully from Mullingar?
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- His surname is Mulholland,
like the street here.
(Kelly laughs)
- So, he's got it all going.
- I love it.
- Molly Mullingar Mulholland.
- Um, so, he-
- I decided it's where they're from.
That's amazing.
(audience giggles)
- She seen it.
I had a shirt on the other day
with Mullingar written on it.
Kelly was like, "Oh, ha!"
(audience laughs)
- But your friend's name is Mully.
That's great.
- Yeah.
And we're, he's like five
weeks, six weeks older than me.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And we're gonna do a joint 30th
'cause I hate-
- [Kelly] (mimics Niall's accent) 30th.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] (continues to mimic
accent) A joint 30th birthday.
- You know-
(Kelly laughs)
- You'd think they would've
got used to me over here
after 13 years?
- Nope.
- [Niall] (in an American
accent) Thirteen.
- We still love it.
Thirteen.
(mimics accent) After 13 years,
I still think it's funny.
No. So, what are y'all going to,
you're gonna be doing big joint thing.
- Yeah, I don't like ...
the last time I celebrated
my birthday was 21.
Went to Vegas, did the whole-
- [Kelly] Wow, that's fun.
- Did the whole deal.
That was, woo.
That was big.
And then I haven't
celebrated really since.
I'm not really a birthday guy,
but 30th I'm definitely gonna do
- Really? The (mimics
accent) 30th one, yeah. So.
(Kelly giggles)
- Kelly, please.
- I'm gonna keep doing it.
- Geez.
- It's awesome. I love it.
So wait, why don't you,
you don't like, you
like just being low key?
- I don't know.
I just like, I'd go for a few
drinks with a few mates, or.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Make sure that there's no cake.
- That's how I do it, yeah.
- Don't like surprises and-
- I hate surprises.
- Hate them.
- Yeah.
- And I also don't like
the happy birthday thing-
- Do you feel pressure to have
to be like, "I love this!"
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- So, don't do that.
If you're gonna surprise me.
- [Kelly] I know.
- I did hear that you don't like
when people sing Happy Birthday to you.
- Hate it.
- So, I'm totally gonna get Shelton
to do that for you on video
to send it to you for your birthday.
(Niall and Kelly laugh)
- No, I don't mind it.
Like, if it's been sent to me or whatever,
but if, you know, when you're in a room.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- The whole room is looking at you
and it's like a 40-second
schpiel compliment thing.
- Yeah. Don't, doesn't
it happen like every time
you end a song on like,
the stage? (giggles)
- Yeah, I guess so.
- [Kelly] (laughs) Yeah.
- It's a, it's a different thing though.
- Don't you hate when people
just sit there and adore you?
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- But you, you can't just
like, you can't start,
(claps hands)
it's not like you can clap along.
- Yeah, yeah. It's hard.
- It's not like you sing along
to your own birthday song.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, I would.
- Yeah, I know you would.
- And yeah, I've just never been,
I've never been a fan of
the birthday thing, but.
- Okay.
Duly noted.
- Yeah.
(Kelly giggles)